c'est trop tard trop rapide pour toi mon
gars j'ai pas que les revues de sub ssa
peu fait bonjour tout le monde
on vient de recevoir ce truc là c'est
incroyable
en vrai c'est un casse tête qui coûte
3000 euros alors quand je dis on vient
de recevoir je ne suis pas surpris parce
que c'est vraiment profonde et ça où on
est on est passé on a passé une steppe
j'ai vu qu'il existait ça c'est fabriqué
en france c est le cas des puzzles qui
fait ça je vous mettrais un lien si vous
voulez voir et là ils ont une série de
casses tête à trois mille balles parce
que vraiment c'est le principe de
dépenser de l'argent un parent il y en a
trente qui existe c'est le 29e
il est extrêmement rare et on a le 29e
du coup sûr 30 alors l'intention du
professeur à l'uqar un petit mot mais
qu'est ce que c'est
dans ce champ mais ce mec est surpris
que ce soit bien pensé à ce prix là
extrait du journal de bord du capitaine
steven abords du glo ici lors de ses
expéditions haute mer ok c'est
extrêmement long à lire moi je vais le
lire et je vous mettrai sur instagram si
vous voulez le dire
[Musique]
ok elle s'appelle la mécanique marque en
référence à son apparence aux mystères
qui l'entourent
nous avons pris l'initiative d'envoyer
le tout un expert en la matière à
certains professeurs au lit car nous
avons l'espoir qui pourrait résoudre
l'énigme est passé militaire ses champs
mais de ouf et vous allez voir la boîte
à malle à côté steampunk c'est donc
ouais je vous disais c'est fabriqué en
france donc ça fait très plaisir
moi c'est le genre d'info qui me rend
heureux vraiment je n'ai jamais ouvert
une boîte je suis pas un brigand en fait
je suis pas un malfrat donc je n'ai
jamais fait ça comme ça je pense qu'il
faut choper les clous et ça va pas non
plus ok mais qu'est ce que c'est il ya
masse chose en fait de bien ça c'est
trop bien et je vous jure que
l'expérience de recevoir une grosse
boîte comme ça avec les clous et touring
ça c'est stylé 1 1
ok style à accra je la voyais plus
grosses que ça dans ma tête
ah ouais 6ème c'est le bisou tout est
monté à la main et toutes les pièces en
fait une par une à la tâche
c'est incroyable
[Musique]
c'est incroyable j'espère que je mette
des heures à la faire en vrai
[Musique]
bon ça démange axe clairement de taper
dedans c'est fou les finitions je pense
que vous avez vues sur les plans que
loïc a fait là avant que je commence je
ne sais pas trop après si ça peut se
refermer si ça sera dans cet état
initial mais quand je vois la cette
partie la halle
rien que celle ci c'est c'est la réal
elle est incroyable je ne sais pas
d'ailleurs le nombre d'heures qu'ils
leur faut pour en fabriquer une bombe je
commence par par tripoter un peu tous
les côtés un pour voir un peu ce qui se
passe parce qu'il n'ya pas de temps de
rien fait qui accroche l'oeil au départ
on dira il faut absolument commencer par
là là on a des rouleaux âge en dessous
on a ce cercle là je reste et du métal
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient beaucoup de
méthane est là dedans et là on a sa part
au dessus y'a rien qui bouge à rien qu'à
l'air de tourner ça ça a l'air d'être
amovible d'accord ça aussi ça doit
l'être sûrement cette partie là ici il
ya ce petit cran la ce petit cran là il
y a pas l'air de voir grand chose ici on
a clairement un mécanisme autour du
norouz qui va falloir bouger qu'on peut
pas pour l'instant pourquoi
déjà parce que je crois que ça va se
lever et donc ça but ici donc ça il
faudrait l'ouvrir là et ça ça pourrait
sortir par là ok si l'aca doit passer
ici ça veut dire que là on doit pouvoir
vous ouvrir ok bon bah il faut il faut
commencer comme ça à tâtons je crois que
je crois que ce casse tête et comme un
oignon loïc un moignon non mais dans le
sens où il ya comme une première couche
à libérer pour atteindre la deuxième
donc là j'ai juste fait ça et je me
demande si du coup je peux pas faire ça
auchan mais ça passe par l'intérieur ok
et donc là ça m'a permis de faire ça ici
et donc ça ça me sert à rien pour le
moment d'y et on dirait que ça libère
quelque chose ça c'est a atteint ta
[ __ ] mais c'est si bien pensé non mais
si mais regardez en fait là quand je
tourne ça maintenant que je peux le
tourner observées ici là et on a la même
chose en bas ça bouge une partie ici
donc là je viens de déloqué sûrement
quelque chose sur cette partie là parce
que ça s'était enfoncé là et je viens de
débloquer quelque chose sur cette partie
là ok du coup est-ce que je reviens là
ça aussi notre loi que je le loupe
j'imagine sauf que lui je peux pas
l'ouvrir actuellement parce qu'il ya
cette espèce d'index qui bloque sa et du
coup c'est index pour le débloquer il
faudrait il faudrait pouvoir bouger sa
[ __ ] elle même la pince et fonctionnel
avec le ressort il faut faire ça et donc
là j'ai quelque chose qui bloque ici en
fait donc il faut que je libère cette
partie du coup comme j'ai libéré ça là
il ya quelques secondes si ça se trouve
ah oui oui bah je peux tourner alors je
peux tourner est ce que ça me sert à
quelque chose de tourner oui parce que
je peux mettre cette encoches ici du
coup la l'encoche en la mettant là en
prenant celui du dessus
je peux ouvrir et donc baisser le doigt
voilà mais c'est tellement déjà je suis
vraiment fan des univers steampunk
mais là si on m'avait dit en postant la
première vidéo de casse tête que je
pressais après un jour donc là je peux
ouvrir ici donc ça libère la et donc ça
j'imagine que c'est un truc qu'on peut
lever wee aa oui d'accord et la regarde
et on ne rend va libérer ce petit truc
là et donc ce cadran en faisant ça donc
on libère une phase qu'on n'a pas encore
touché et sur laquelle on peut
potentiellement rien faire pour
l'instant j'ai l'impression je pas envie
d'y aller trop fort ce que ça me ferait
vraiment chier de casser quelque chose
quoi il va falloir tout bougeait comme
ça là en fait puisqu'on a des espèces de
pitou you ici j'imagine très bien qu'il
va falloir tourner l'ensemble vers la
gauche
mais j'ai pas encore la possibilité de
le faire là ici il ya quelque chose qui
bloque donc en fait il ya quelque chose
qui bloquait là on l'a libéré là on l'a
libéré ici j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils
aient quelque chose là il ya quelque
chose alors ça est-ce qu'on peut le
passer dans le trou là ouais ça suffit
de comptes n'ont suffi pas ça
ok donc là c'est lui que je veux
désenclenché et c'est que ce truc là et
là est ce que ça peut rentrer là dedans
j'ai l'impression coup de tête en
bougeant lyon à je l'avais pas ouvert à
fond j'avais pas ouvert lui à fond donc
il pouvait pas rentrer dans l'encoche là
ce qui fait que j'ai pu baisser là donc
je dois pouvoir tourner au la times vous
leur fais j'aime trouver j'aime beaucoup
trop en dire le nautilus ici on a une
flèche
vous voyez ce héros tels la chaîne art
au post it master qui me dit tourner ça
vers la droite
non ça dit pas ce à quoi ça correspond
ça a l'air d'être complètement bloquée
alors attention un récap des faces ça on
a libéré ça on peut pas encore ouvrir ça
on n'est jamais venu encore ici mais
c'est peut-être qu'il ya ça avec le
symbole kiala là on a une loupe avec le
truc cadenas comme si l'ensemble allait
servir un cadenas et ce qu'anna étant
peut-être celui-là
ah non non non c'est ce truc là en fait
au jeu peu vrai ah non non j'ai eu
l'impression que je pouvais mais non ici
je pense qu'on est libérées tout ce
qu'ils avaient libéré c'est à dire cette
pincée cette pince là ici qu'est ce
qu'on a fait ici
ah oui on l'a mis ici celle là
désenclenché là on a toutes ouvertes a
permis de lever sa entre autres là bas
on a ouvert ce qu'il va ouvrir
il ya juste ce truc là mais on peut pas
y aller je veux surtout pas forcément
y'a que ce côté là qu'on a vraiment pas
encore essayé de taper et qui m'a l'air
un peu plus complexe un peu plus énigme
donc on a cinq symboles ici les symboles
c'est sur ces les phases de cette boîte
mois celle ci puisqu'il ya 6 face à un
cube
il ya forcément les cinq autres face ça
avec la main ça doit représenter cette
phase là où il y avait la main ça avec
les deux trucs qui tournait ça doit
représenter cette phase là quand s'était
refermée le mental ça doit représenter
le vortex convient d'ouvrir ici et ça
ça doit représenter ce côté là et du
coup les trois cercles les quatre
cercles là ce serait quoi
c'est le seul qu'on n'a pas fait ce sera
lui par élimination c'est forcément du
coup sans des boutons qu'on peut tourner
je sais pas si vous voyez bien mais il
ya une petite flèche en fait sur chaque
bouton et il ya des symboles autour des
cadrans et alors ces symboles
je crois que ces symboles ben si c'est
dans l'ordre alors je suis sûr de ma
théorie ça ça veut dire 1 2 3 4 et 5
pourquoi me direz-vous parce que c'est
un truc qu'on a déjà vu dans des casses
tête ou dans des énigmes que j'aime eux
mêmes mots crémer genre dans le casse
tête que m'avait créer un abonné que
vous pourrez regarder en enchaînement de
cette vidéo
en fait c'est le nombre de traits qui
compte là il faut un trait pour faire
une ligne de trait pour faire un b3 très
pour faire un triangle 4è pour faire un
carré et 5 très pour faire un pentagone
et c'est exactement comme ça que tout a
été fait c'est un deux trois quatre cinq
au lieu de mettre 1 2 3 4 5
ils ont juste omis des symboles donc il
va falloir mettre je pense une séquence
1 2 3 4 5 dans un ordre précis et il
faut trouver quel est cet ordre pour
l'instant on a avancé gravite un dessus
un fait remarquer d'où te vient cette
joie de vivre lolita yard
[Musique]
et est-ce que c'est l'ordre dans
laquelle j'ai touché des faces c'est
quoi le premier truc que j'ai fait
c'était de bouger ça donc ça c'était mon
ce côté là puisque j'ai d'abord bouger
ce truc là y'avait rien qu'il retenait
donc on peut dire un pour lui gelé bien
ok une fois que je les bouger lui on a
bougé lui ou pas oui il n'ya plus rien
qui retenait donc j'ai bougé lui donc ça
ça faisait 2 pour sa dette a en vain eh
ben je l'aï presque une somme de leur
part qu'ils pédalent vendeville donc lui
ce serait 2 en 3 du coup une fois que
lui je les bouger qu'est ce que ça a
libéré le fait de bouger sa libérer ces
trucs là et du cou du coup ça a libéré
la et du coup j'ai pu tourner lui je
crois je pense que c'était lui donc les
cercles mais sur le triangle parce que
le triangle
il est composé de trois lignes bien sûr
hockey en est du coup lui sera en quatre
j'ai l'impression que c'était avant lui
j'ai l'impression que j'avais fait ça là
avant un temps pourquoi je pouvais pas
le retirer de sa vie un truc glauque et
lui balance si c'est maintenant ça doit
être ça donc en 4 j'ai dû faire la main
ok et du coup en 5
le vortex bien sûr
ok et donc ça ça d'être le bouton pour
ouvrir j'ai fait ça c'est bon ok bombay
la théorie était bonne je suis ou très
bon ou c'est est très logique
ok donc ça veut dire que ça veut dire ça
ferait donc là je viens de faire ça ça
m'a permis de lever satin par contre la
mecanica l'eifel 1 donc ça veut dire que
j'ai libéré un truc au vortex au fameux
à touvois pas que j'ai ouvert la boîte 1
non mais là toi tu vois pas une voix
mais la [ __ ] non mais c'est fou une
cas des puzzles boxe c'est la ronde qui
est le l'inventeur de mécanique ma
france et la numérotation 2020 13
annonce était la 13e fabrique
je crois qu'il ya un lien n'avait aller
les autres sont peut-être juste réservé
mais pas encore construite si ça se
trouve
rolala s'étouffe est atteint il ya plein
de trucs dedans mais c'est un délice à
résoudre cette box par contre je suis
allé quand même super ravie
on n'a même pas fait d'accélérations y
avait quand même un autre truc il ya des
salles il y avait ça dedans mais je me
suis sincère on verra peut-être la
prochaine fois ce que c'est mais j'ai
l'impression que non une clé qui doit
ouvrir la grosse boîte qui avait avec
dans le colis
nous avons également c'est très très
bien emballé c'est presque trop bien
emballé un jamais même l'odeur aller
steampunk ses larmes quand même ok
adacore au kansas était une part et et
un truc un peu de d'oiseaux rugolo ceux
de petits cadeaux je pense de même qu'à
des puzzles qu'ils ont mis dedans plus
mécaniquement on hamm est là mais là je
vais essayer d'ouvrir serpent dans ce
cas là dedans ça ne s'arrête donc jamais
alors c'est tout vert monsieur mais même
la boîte à l'est ce qu'il est mais celle
ci c'est fou quand même ça ne s'arrête
jamais
fineo ce n'est jamais fini en continu à
temps tu peux m'approcher la grosse
caisse s'il te plaît sachez vaucluse et
de la batterie se révèle un tout petit
peu je ressens tu me trouves
non messieurs les bleus un tout petit
peu lâche lâche tout pas trop mais lâche
tout non mais la chose de pas trop et
voilà tu es encore largué une caisse a
été pas mal
elle n'était pas bien longue elle était
l'image s'est tu sais que tu as à tarbes
à parce que c'est pas toi qui va faire
le ménage je faisais gaffe à tout public
est ce que c'est que ça est ce que c'est
[Applaudissements]
non non non je crois savoir ce que c'est
lolo c'est un moteur mais c'est mais
c'est fou en vrai si vous connaissez pas
c'est complètement
c'est un moteur carling ça a été inventé
en fin de neuvième ça le truc et gorille
certains décident de science des sites
de sciences à temps en temps on va
essayer de l'assemblée et ça te sert de
trophées en fait que les citations tu a
vaincu mécanisme
ah bah oui bien sûr il faut le faire
brûler évidemment d'un briquet toi à
personne un briquet ou aussi il nous
faudrait quand même un combustible mais
au moins je vais vous faire voir comment
ça fonctionne même si je peux pas le
faire fonctionner je vous ferai voir sur
sur mon instinct qui apparaît ici sur le
mien
parce qu'elle est sera chez moi
d'écouter ça le c'est bizarre tu vas
venir chez moi non
alors non la petite comme on dit tout
cas sa place à cépie ça quand même
voici ce 40 tirs ligne il se dit je vais
faire un petit moteur style et c'est à
dire que la chaleur ici elle va chauffer
l'air et l'air du coup va changer va
être obligé de se compresser ou de
décompresser ce qui va faire bouger ce
piston qui va le reculer
et puis comme ça refroidit et ben ça va
faire ça et puis a perdu et ça a fait
comme ça un moteur de voiture peut-être
et du coup après avec ça et bien tu peux
utiliser cette énergie mécanique ou tu
veux pour connecter autre chose
là en l'occurrence je le vois il ya une
petite led qui a été mise ici mon
pourrait mettre un petit ventilateur
style et un petit truc comme ça ça je
vais les laisser là je vais essayer de
refermer la boîte et après je me fais un
petit bonus
[Musique]
ok j'ai fait le reset de ça parce que
j'aimerais bien voir les hôtes essayé au
cas où ça s'ajuste l'air d'être des
cadeaux un peu style et dans la notice
en vidéo
et après ça se place juste au dessus ou
michel gerald hassell montjoie fait
d'accord c'est tout ok bah c'est juste
une petite mignonneries tu vois pour la
fête des mères
regarde j'ai mes petits oiseaux y sont
venus manger rappelle rien ils avaient
les crocs là les miens par contre il y
en a toujours un ou deux cas fin et pas
le choix en fait mais moi j'ai faim ah
j'ai pu faire un vrai mais moi j'ai faim
en grèce était trop stylé c'est la
première fois que je dépense autant que
tulle pour un casse tête mais je suis
ravie quand je vois le matériel que j'ai
eu le trophée la mécanique ma les petits
cadeaux qui à l'intérieur sur l'appareil
je vous fait gagner sur un stade
celui-là je le garde parce qu'il est
vraiment trop trop millions et le fait
en plus d'avoir la clé pour une autre
boîte qui à l'intérieur la grosse de
bois de départ qu'on reçoit trouve ça
trop cool c'est aussi je vous ferai voir
sur install comment ça fonctionne parce
qu'on a pas de briques et ici il nous
n'avons pas le petit carburant qu'il
faudrait mettre dedans
je suis ravie prochaine étape les les où
les casse-têtes à 20000 et c'est
fabriqué en france aussi mais là il va
falloir développer pour ça je vous le
dire vous allez vous fait quelques op
fort des jeux vidéo des trucs comme ça
c'est une certitude c'était trop cool
merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo j'espère que vous avez lâché un
gros like pour faire d'investissements
mais surtout pour cette boîte
hallucinante
vous avez compris qu'ils avaient tout
sur mon instagram comme d'habitude
pensez à vous abonner sinon vous voyez
pas les autres vidéos passé donc à qu'il
est bien la cloche ça c'est important de
faire ça vous pouvez même mettre ces
vidéos là je vais être notifiée
absolument en priorité et où je sais pas
si vous aviez percuté que mon nouveau
livre était sorti je ne vais pas là mais
loïc l'a peut-être
certes vous avez un lien dans la
description pour voir un petit peu ce
que c'est dire quelques pages par si
vous avez envie de dire que ça ou pas
moi ici je vous mets une vidéo sur
excalibur qui était quand même bien
chaud comme casquette et ça c'est le
dernier casse tête qu'on est fait sur la
chaîne à savoir un cigare dans une fiole
il faut dévisser à l'intérieur de la
fiole c'était relou mais c'était très
cool aussi
merci à vous et à très bientôt ciao